Transcription: Gianluca Valente
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Alors bonsoir Belfort,
est-ce que vous
vous sentez bien dans le noir ?
Vous entendez ma voix,
qui est là pour vous guider.
Alors, j’espère que
vous allez avoir confiance.
Si j’ai décidé de démarrer
mon speech dans le noir,
c’est que je vais vous raconter
une histoire insolite, mon histoire,
mais aussi celle d’un restaurant
pas comme les autres,
où, justement,
on mange dans le noir absolu
guidé par des personnes non-voyantes.
Et vous allez vous rendre compte
que la notion de confiance
est centrale dans cette histoire.
Mais comme vous le savez,
les conférences TEDx sont filmées.
Alors, je vous propose
que nous continuions en lumière.
Voilà, et ça va vous permettre
de constater que non, je ne fais pas 1m70
et que je n’ai pas les cheveux noirs.
Peut-être que mon accent
a pu vous induire en erreur.
Alors, mon histoire démarre
à la fin des années 90.
Je viens d’arriver à Paris,
en provenance de mon Sud natal.
Je viens de terminer des études
de commerce international
et de psychologie,
mais qui m’ont peu passionné.
Je cherche du travail,
mais je me retrouve
à enchaîner les travaux alimentaires.
Bref, je me cherche.
Alors, il y a sans doute
des parents, dans la salle,
et les parents, ils ont toujours...
ils se font du souci pour leurs enfants,
quand ils se cherchent de la sorte.
Eh bien il ne faut pas,
car il suffit qu’ils trouvent leur voie,
et il faut leur donner la confiance
afin qu’ils y parviennent.
Moi, j’avais une chose qui m’a guidé
à cette époque,
une intuition,
une petite voix intérieure qui me disait :
« Fabrice,
il faut que tu mettes du sens
dans ton travail. »
Et c’est cette même petite voix
qui m’a aussi guidé
quand j’ai accepté, contre toute attente,
un poste
de responsable des projets culturels
et sportifs
pour une association
pour aveugles et malvoyants.
Je ne connaissais absolument rien
à la non-voyance,
j’avais même été pris,
dans un autre poste,
pour gérer une salle de concert.
J’adorais la musique
et tous mes amis me disaient :
« C’est ça que tu dois faire. »
Mais moi, mon intuition, elle m’a dit :
« Le sens,
c’est plutôt du côté des non-voyants
que tu vas le trouver ».
J’avais aussi également été marqué
par la rencontre
avec les personnes non-voyantes.
Leur enthousiasme, leur énergie,
m’avaient véritablement emporté.
J’ai tout de suite eu confiance en eux,
et eux en moi, manifestement,
car ils m’ont demandé,
ils ont insisté
pour que je rejoigne leurs rangs.
Et j’ai dit banco,
j’ai foncé dans cette direction.
Eh bien m’en a pris,
car,
six mois après mon arrivée,
un projet va changer
radicalement mon existence.
Un créatif, du nom de Michel Aurillac,
vient à notre rencontre.
Il a un projet expérimental,
de dîners dans le noir
guidés par des non-voyants.
Comme je viens d’arriver à l’association,
on me dit : « Tu vas t’en occuper. »
Alors ça a suscité pas mal
de scepticisme au début,
même à l’association pour les non-voyants.
Manger dans le noir,
guidés par nos non-voyants,
mais quelle drôle d’idée !
Pourtant, moi, j’ai senti tout de suite
le potentiel de ce projet.
Je décide de m'investir corps et âme.
Je recrute la première équipe
de guides non-voyants.
Et de fil en aiguille, je me retrouve
directeur de production
de ce qui va devenir
en fait, le premier restaurant
“dans le noir” au monde.
Alors nous ne savions pas non plus
ce qui allait se passer du côté du public.
À l’époque, il n’y avait pas
de réseaux sociaux,
mais je sens, dès les premiers tests,
qu’il se passe quelque chose.
En effet, le bouche-à-oreille commence
à se mettre en place.
Nous avons un premier article,
dans Libération,
je me rappelle, une pleine page,
et puis, ça a fait boule de neige,
et tous les autres journaux viennent.
Et là, à partir de là,
le succès est fulgurant.
Nous sommes archi-complets
et nous avons des centaines de personnes
en file d’attente.
le projet était monté à l’époque comme
une exposition, de manière temporaire,
et malheureusement,
les salles ne sont plus disponibles.
Non, nous devons arrêter le projet.
Michel Aurillac nous quitte
et part rejoindre Arte,
il nous demande de continuer.
Je me retrouve à organiser des sessions
temporaires de dîners dans le noir,
et là, le destin
va à nouveau frapper à ma porte.
En effet, je vais faire la rencontre
d’un autre personnage important
dans l’histoire,
Edouard de Broglie.
Alors, Edouard, c’est un entrepreneur,
il s’intéresse à la responsabilité sociale
et environnementale des entreprises.
Il vient de publier un ouvrage
qui s’appelle
“La marque face à l’éthique”.
Il cherche des idées pour développer
une entreprise utile.
Ça aurait pu être dans n’importe quoi,
mais il se trouve
qu’il a vécu l’expérience
du dîner en noir.
Il vient donc nous rencontrer,
et il souhaite créer à Paris
le premier restaurant permanent,
créer une véritable entreprise.
Alors, j’aurais pu ne pas avoir
confiance en Édouard :
nous sommes très différents,
nous sommes issus de milieux différents,
nous avons des parcours différents,
nous avons même des caractères différents.
Pourtant, ça a tout de suite
matché entre nous,
j’ai tout de suite apprécié
son audace,
et sa détermination.
Édouard a une vision que je partage,
et moi,
j’ai un savoir-faire unique,
qui va lui être utile.
Nous joignons nos forces
pour ensemble ouvrir
le premier restaurant
dans le noir à Paris.
Alors,
nous, nous avions confiance en nous
et dans notre idée,
mais ce n’était pas le cas
de tout le monde,
et nous allons rapidement devoir
faire face à de multiples obstacles.
Le premier,
va concerner le financement du projet :
les banques.
Alors ce n’est pas la peine
que je vous fasse la liste,
elles ont toutes dit non.
Nous avons essuyé 13 refus bancaire,
un record.
Alors, il y a aussi peut-être
des entrepreneurs dans la salle,
et ils le savent bien,
quand on développe un projet nouveau,
ben, ce n’est pas facile
de convaincre les financiers,
ils détestent les risques.
Mais il faut,
il faut parfois défendre ses convictions
contre tous les autres
et prendre des risques.
“Dans le noir” sera donc un projet
100% autofinancé,
et, il faut le souligner,
en grande partie
sur les deniers personnels d’Édouard.
Le second obstacle
que nous allons recontrer,
ça va se passer au niveau des autorités.
Il faut, pour ouvrir cet ultime talisman,
des autorisations spéciales.
À Paris, c’est très compliqué.
À Londres, c'est pire.
Je me souviens que nous avons assisté
à une réunion,
au Council, à Londres,
où une personne s’était dressée,
pendant la réunion, et nous avait dit:
« Moi, vivant, jamais
vous n’ouvrirez cet établissement ».
Ça m’a fait très très mal.
Mais, là aussi,
à force de détermination, et de travail,
nous avons réussi à gagner leur confiance
et à obtenir les précieux sésames.
J’ai notamment développé un système
de sécurité unique au monde,
avec de blocs de secours spéciaux
qui sont reliés à des batteries.
Enfin,
ça n’a pas été simple non plus
du côté des non-voyants.
Il y a d’abord eu ceux, issus du milieu
associatif, qui nous disaient:
« Mais vous allez exploiter
les non-voyants ! »
Et là, nous devions leur expliquer que,
bien sûr, que nous allons
exploiter les non-voyants,
ça ne va pas être des bénévoles.
Nous allons créer des emplois,
leur donner du travail
et donc exploiter leur force de travail.
Et puis, il fallait aussi recruter
nos équipes et les former.
Et bon nombre des non-voyants
qui venaient à nous,
étaient en perte totale de confiance.
Une grosse partie
de mon travail au départ,
ça a été de leur redonner confiance.
J’ai donc développé
des processus de formation,
basés sur l’approche tactile
et la motivation.
Ainsi, nous les avons rendus performants,
et je dois dire qu’aujourd’hui,
ils font un travail remarquable.
Ce sont eux les véritables stars
de nos établissements.
Et nous sommes très fiers,
à “Dans le noir”,
de compter 50% de personnes en situation
de handicap, au sein de nos équipes.
Et sans faire partie du secteur protégé,
sans aucune subvention.
Ça représente, quand même,
plus de 80 emplois à travers le monde,
et des centaines d’emplois créés
depuis notre créatio
il y a près de 20 ans.
On peut dire que “Dans le noir”
a un vrai impact social.
Enfin, il faut que je vous parle aussi
de la confiance,
et du côté de nos clients.
Alors là, c’est le moment
de vous expliquer un petit peu, davantage,
comment ça fonctionne
dans nos établissements.
Alors, la première chose
que font nos clients, quand ils arrivent,
ils arrivent dans une salle éclairée,
et ils mettent leur affaires
dans des casiers, qu’ils ferment à clé.
Leur veste, leurs sacs
et leurs téléphones portables.
Alors, vous allez voir,
nous y reviendrons,
c’est important.
Donc, les casiers fermés à clé.
La deuxième chose qu’ils font, eh bien,
c’est d’aller aux toilettes.
Alors là, je vous le dis tout net,
non, nos toilettes
ne sont pas dans le noir.
Alors là, c’est nous qui n’avons
absolument pas eu confiance.
Les messieurs visent déjà
très mal en lumière,
hein, n’est-ce pas?
Alors,
Alors, dans le noir, c’était impossible.
Trêve de plaisanteries,
quand vous êtes passés aux toilettes,
notre équipe d’accueil vient
à votre rencontre et prend vos commandes.
Il note scrupuleusement
vos restrictions alimentaires.
Et puis, quand le groupe est prêt,
ils appellent votre guide non-voyant
qui vient vous accueillir devant la salle.
Là, il vous demande de vous mettre
en file indienne,
donc vous mettez la main
sur l'épaule de la personne
qui vous précède.
Et il va ensuite guider le groupe
à travers un sas qui permet de basculer,
progressivement, de la lumière
vers le noir absolu.
Il vous guide, dans la salle,
jusqu’à votre table, vous installe,
vous explique
tout ce qu’il y a autour de vous.
Puis, il commence le service des plats.
Alors, observons là ce qui se passe
au niveau de la confiance,
dans cette expérience absolument unique.
Il y a trois dimensions fondamentales
et importantes dans l’expérience:
la dimension sociale, la dimension
sensorielle et la dimension humaine.
Alors, au niveau social,
vous rappelez les personnes
qui avaient laissé leur téléphone ?
Qu’est-ce qui va se passer pour eux ?
Eh bien, ils vont se reconnecter
avec eux mêmes.
Ils vont se reconnecter avec l’instant,
ils vont se reconnecter aussi
avec les autres,
et ils vont redécouvrir un plaisir
simple, mais ô combien essentiel:
c’est le fait de se parler.
Et ils vont échanger
de manière plus intense,
plus authentique,
sans les a priori
liés aux jugements visuels.
Alors, vous avez des coups de bluff assez
incroyables au restaurant “Dans le noir”.
On peut avoir un hipster,
super looké, assis à côté,
je ne sais pas,
d’un conducteur de locomotive,
qui n’a que faire un peu
de sa tenue vestimentaire.
En lumière, sans doute,
qui ne se seraient jamais parlés.
Mais là, dans le noir,
ils vont se trouver sympas
et ils vont discuter, échanger,
et apprendre plein de choses.
Alors, au niveau sensoriel,
on vous propose aussi
de déguster un menu surprise,
dont vous ne savez pas
ce que vous allez manger.
Et là, vous devez réveiller vos sens
et refaire confiance à vos sens.
L’odorat, par exemple,
qui est un peu endormi,
que vous allez utiliser un peu
comme les animaux,
pour humer vos aliments
avant de les mettre en bouche.
Votre toucher, aussi tactile,
mais, vous allez explorer
votre environnement,
et parfois redécouvrir,
comme les enfants, le plaisir enfantin
de saisir la nourriture avec les doigts.
Et enfin, votre ouïe, est exacerbée.
Vous entendez tous les sons
autour de vous.
Et surtout, vous écoutez
la parole de l’autre.
Enfin, au niveau de la dimension humaine,
eh bien, vous n’êtes pas accueillis
par n’importe qui, dans nos restaurants.
Vous êtes accueillis par des personnes
non-voyantes.
Et là, on peut dire qu’il y a
un véritable transfert de confiance,
des voyants vers les non-voyants.
On inverse complètement les rôles,
et ils deviennent vos yeux et vous guident
pendant toute l’expérience,
et ça va changer radicalement
la perception de ce handicap.
Dans ce contexte, les handicapés,
ce n’est plus eux, c’est vous.
Alors, c’est une espérance qui soulève
beaucoup de questions,
et je ne sais pas
si vous avez remarqué, mais,
à notre marque,
il y a un point d’interrogation là.
Il n'est pas là par hasard.
Il symbolise en fait toute l’équipe,
toutes les questions qu’on peut se poser,
notamment sur les a priori.
Albert Einstein, disait
« Il est plus facile de désintégrer un
atome plutôt qu’un a priori. »
Et on peut dire que “Dans le noir”,
c’est un vrai désintégrateur d’a priori.
Alors moi, je ne sais pas
ce qu’ils sont devenus,
rappelez vous, les sceptiques du départ,
tous ces banquiers qui n’y croyaient pas,
mais aujourd'hui, j'aimerais,
j'aimerais les revoir.
J’aimerais m’asseoir avec eux
autour d’une table, et je leur dirais,
à l’époque, vous n’avez pas eu confiance,
vous n’avez pas su voir la perspective.
Pourtant, aujourd’hui, “Dans le noir”,
eh bien, c’est douze établissements
à travers le monde.
C’est près de 2 millions de personnes
accueillies
au sein de nos établissements,
depuis nos débuts,
il y a près de vingt ans.
Et des établissements
qui sont toujours pleins,
même aujourd’hui
après la crise du Covid,
qui nous a poussés à innover
et à installer des machines
qui filtrent l’air à un micron,
et qui nous permet d’être top
dans la sécurité de l’air,
un peu comme dans les hôpitaux.
Alors “Dans le noir” aussi, alors, c’est
aussi des groupes hôteliers qui viennent
à notre rencontre aujourd’hui,
et qui nous demandent
de créer des “dans le noir”
au sein de leur
établissement, ce qui nous permet
de créer de la valeur,
mais aussi du trafic.
Et alors ?
J’ai une petite information étonnante
à partager avec vous.
Après avoir ouvert justement à Nantes
à Bordeaux et à Toulouse,
comme l’a dit Christian,
nous avons ouvert à Strasbourg.
Eh bien, figurez vous que grâce au travail
remarquable de nos équipes,
eh bien “Dans le noir” Strasbourg
est aujourd’hui premier sur TripAdvisor,
parmi les restaurants à Strasbourg,
quelle plus belle preuve de réussite !
Alors, moi aussi, j’ai continué
mon aventure et j’ai continué à innover.
Et après avoir ouvert des établissements
à travers le monde,
et bien j’ai créé aussi
un département événementiel,
ce qui m’a permis
de travailler avec des marques,
avec des institutions, pour développer
avec eux des projets porteurs de sens.
Par exemple, j’ai créé,
au Futuroscope de Poitiers,
une attraction,
qui s’appelle “Les yeux grands fermés”,
et qui est un parcours dans le noir,
c’est l’attraction.
Elle arrive, régulièrement, en tête
des enquêtes de satisfaction.
C’est quand même un comble,
dans un parc dédié à l’image.
J’ai aussi créé
de véritables voyages sensoriels
avec des marques comme L’Oréal ou LVMH,
et j’ai fait découvrir leurs produits
par une approche différente de stimulation
des sens et de l’imaginaire.
Enfin, beaucoup de projets, passionnants,
que vous avez compris qu’ils sont mis
en place par de véritables passionnés.
Alors moi, j’ai été ravi, ce soir,
de partager un petit peu avec vous,
cette histoire.
J’espère que ça vous aura permis
de prendre conscience,
eh bien,
qu’il faut avoir confiance
dans ses intuitions,
et encore plus dans ses rêves.
Il faut avoir confiance dans ses capacités
pour surmonter les obstacles,
et ne jamais rien lâcher.
Et enfin, avoir confiance dans les autres,
car on ne réussit jamais tous seuls.
Mais, si on observe cette notion de
confiance que l’on donne, que l’on reçoit,
on ne sait jamais vraiment,
si ça va marcher.
En fait, on est un peu
comme dans nos salles noires.
Finalement, la confiance,
c’est toujours une confiance aveugle.
Merci.